[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's pat 40 sports illustrated writer
covers college basketball and
college football where do we stand with
the sec this weekend pat
uh well one game down texas a m is not
playing which
becomes increasingly problematic for
them hopefully they can reschedule
because they're a playoff contender and
this will be two games that they haven't
played so far
maybe they can get them both in uh
everywhere else is kind of like hold
your breath and see
you know usually dan if you have a one
week problem it's a two-week problem
uh so we'll see if any of these other
games are going to get canceled uh
after four of them last week but you
know so far
that's the only one that's been
announced and
how many games we see in the big ten and
that if you missed two games then you're
not gonna be able to qualify for the big
ten
championship i believe but uh you know
the sec
built in a little bit of breathing space
but you know
how much breathing space do you have
before a game actually gets canceled not
postponed
yeah we're running out of it for sure
there's going to be some teams that
probably will not
play the full complement of games what
they've been looking at with some of
them
uh is trying to schedule them on
december 19th which is the date of the
sec championship
but they you know if you're not playing
in that you could still play a game
uh like for now i think they they're
looking at georgia at missouri on
december 19th in a game that
boy the bulldogs should just be rife
with motivation for because they'd be
out of
championship contention out of playoff
contention and get to go play in the
coldest town in the sec
in a game that doesn't matter at all are
we headed for florida alabama sec title
game
yeah i think it's uh almost inevitable
at this point like
florida both teams would really have to
screw it up they would
they'd have to lose twice most likely
uh because you know they've won the
head-to-head against their their closest
pursuer
alabama blew out texas a m florida blue
out georgia so they they would have to
lose twice so yeah we're looking at that
and
basically i think that's winner gets
into the playoff and possibly even loser
gets in if florida if alabama's
undefeated florida has one loss and
florida wins
i think there's a chance they both go
and i don't know if the heisman comes
down to
florida alabama for the sec title uh
with kyle trask
and mack jones that could it hinge on
that
it's entirely possible you know we'll
see where things stand with the rest of
the country where trevor lawrence is
where justin fields is and
even where zach wilson from byu is but
yeah that that would be
that game figures to be a crazy shootout
if it's alabama florida you know that
that's not
going to be pat dye against bear bryant
sec that's going to be like 49 to 42
so that would be a big showcase game for
those two quarterbacks
i don't know if i'm overstating this but
you know gene chiswick got that
one year honeymoon at auburn when he won
a national title is ed orgeron
in that one year honeymoon period is is
he on a warm seat at all at lsu
well there's there's definitely some
similarities there in terms of like the
precipitous drop-off
uh i think he has recruited too well to
for this to be a long-term situation
you know they should bounce back but
they are really bad this year
and they've got a lot of other stuff
going on there obviously they've got an
ncaa investigation that includes
football not necessarily for anything
that happened while orgeron was the head
coach
but uh they've got that and then you
know the usa today report this week was
very disturbing about the number of
uh you know alleged sexual assaults and
other incidents uh
regarding women there that some of which
involve football players so
uh things are definitely not trending
the right direction for ed orgeron
after the year when every single thing
went right he's pat 40 sports
illustrated writer covering college
basketball college football had a column
yesterday
where you're not giving mulligans to
some of these coaches based off what's
going on with covid
run down the list of those coaches who
don't get mulligans
yeah obviously will must champshire
didn't uh he's out and
even if it's going to cost south
carolina 13 million dollars for him to
leave
jim harbaugh is not getting a mulligan
now is he going to get fired
no but you know the chance is very
strong that he and
michigan both just look at each other
and say yeah we tried but
it's time to move on yeah i think that's
that's likely to happen
uh james franklin does get a mulligan
we'll see about clay helton at usc right
i mean they're 2-0 but they're the
luckiest 2-0 in the country
so i don't know you know what his
chances are there
i'm trying to think who else i had on
the list here
um but you know obviously the the
mulligan aspect comes into play because
do people want to pony up that kind of
money when they're losing that much
money
and so some coaches have gotten you know
a pass i think on having bad seasons
this year
if indiana beats ohio state this weekend
what level of
upset is that oh i think it's pretty
darn major
and that's not to say that indiana isn't
good i mean they are they're 4-0 and
they're legit
this is your defense is playing better
than any time in the 21st century
michael penix is a great quarterback the
receivers are outstanding
but still across the board they don't
have ohio state's talent
they don't have ohio state's experience
in these situations
uh there's just nothing from a
you know 35 000 foot view
there's no reason for indiana football
to you know walk into columbus and beat
ohio state
uh so it would be it would be a major
upset it would be a complete upheaval of
big ten hierarchy and orthodoxy
i don't think it'll happen but they can
stay in the game with them yeah
vegas has some 21 point underdogs we'll
talk to indiana's head coach on the
program tomorrow
ncaa looking into bubblizing the entire
march madness in indianapolis
your initial thoughts i like it i think
it's a good idea i think it's a good
solution
you know it's a great national
tournament coast to coast but let's be
real about the circumstances here and
i think if you if you feel like this is
the best way to get the tournament done
you do it and indy is the perfect place
for it i mean it's
not only ncaa headquarters but it's a
basketball city it's a
really centralized downtown it's they've
got
tons of venues to use whether it's high
school gyms i've got
you know most of the biggest high school
gyms in the country or whether you
expand a little bit and go down to
assembly hall or over to mackie arena
um you know depending how big their
radius they want for this but
you know the bigger issue for the ncaa
is just getting there getting the season
started
is difficult having some of these events
has been
uh proven to be really complicated and
arduous and so we'll see how many games
they can even get in getting this thing
off the ground before we get to having a
tournament
at the end well i think that these
schools are going to be helped out once
thanksgiving rolls around and all the
students leave campus and then basically
you're bubblizing your basketball team
on campus i think
that'll help the question is when you
travel
uh you know are you going into a campus
where nobody is on campus there or how
are you able to schedule these games but
but i think keeping your team safe will
be a whole lot easier
in the next week or so no doubt about it
if you if you talk to coaches either
football or basketball they're like
please just let us get to this point
where
as as weird as it sounds please let us
have a deserted campus with just our
athletes
here you know and get all these regular
students out of college but
that's what they all want for that very
reason the socializing ends the
you know the parties are reduced and and
you
you're not traveling into other places
where you're going into a 40 000
student campus safe travels pat as
always we appreciate your time thanks
for joining us
hey my pleasure thank you dan that's pat
40 sports illustrator writer covering
college basketball
and football